منصات التواصل مليانه دعوات للتبرع
والتطوع ودعوات للمتضررين وتداول الصور
والمقاطع ولكن وللاسف ومثل اللي بصير مع
اي كارثه او حدث كبير كمان شايفين كثير
معلومات غريبه عجيبه متداوله على المنصات
نحن عارفين هذه حقيقه ولا خرافه ولا ايش
وانا ترى ما بتكلم عن تغريده الباحث
الهولندي اللي تكلمنا فيها امس واللي قيل
انه تنبا فيها بحدوث الزلزال لا احنا الان
بنتكلم عن اشياء اكبر من كذب كثير المنصات
مليانه معلومات وتحليلات الواحد مو فاهم
هذه حقائق مستنده للشيء علمي ولا خرافات
ولا تخبيص يعني يعني في منها صراحه من
غرابته واضح جدا انه تاليف لكن في اشياء
ثانيه فعليا الواحد مو عارف يصدقها او لا
يعني في ناس بتقول لك الزلزال له علاقه
بتوقف لب الارض عن الدوران واللي توصلنا
علماء من ايام وكنا حتى نناقشنا نحن في
حلقه سابقه من تفاعلكم وقال لك بس هذا هو
اكيد هو السبب والعالم خلاص بينتهي لانه
وقتها لو تتذكروا قالوا لب الارض توقف
وحيعكس دوران وفكلا الشمس حتشرق من الغرب
والان زلزال فقال لك خلاص هذه علامات
الساعه والعالم بينتهي فينا ناس ثانيه
قالت لك لا مو لب الارض بس السماء وقالت
لك الزلزال اكيد له علاقه بالمذنب الاخضر
اللي مر بالقرب مننا في الارض لاول مره من
خمسين سنه قبل خمسه ايام في ناس ثانيه عاد
قالت لك مو البشر اللي تنباؤوا بالزلزال
بل الحيوانات وتداوله فيديو للطيور في
تركيا وقالوا شوفوا كيف حركه الطيور مو
طبيعيه اكيد كانوا حاسين وعارفين انه
الزلزال جيد ناس تانيه قالت لا مو الطيور
هدول اغنام فاكرين الفيديو الاغنام العجيب
اللي في الصين والاردن من اسابيع واللي
كده كانوا بيلفوا فيه دوائر والناس قالت
مو فاهمين ايش هذا اليوم طلع الناس قالوا
بس خلاص فهمنا اكيد هدول الاغنام حاسين
بالزلزال من قبل طيب كم تحليلات ومعلومات
بتخلي الواحد محتاج انه يسمع رايي علمي
فينضم الينا دكتور محمد قاسم عضو مجلس
اداره المدرسه الرقميه انا محتاجه منك
دكتور محمد انك تكون هادئ وتتعامل مع هذه
الامور بهدوء والاشياء اللي حتسمعها بهدوء
طيب
خلينا نبتدي باول شيء قصه لب الارض
طبعا هذه لحد الحين انا ما شفت للعلماء اي
تجاوب على هذا الموضوع انه بالارض لها
علاقه او ما شابه فاعتقد في هذه ننتظر حتى
نشوف العلماء شو يقولون ولو
كان لب الارض هو الاشكال لا سمعنا هذا
الخبر من زمان اعتقد هاي الصفائح
التكتونيه قاعد تتحرك وخلونا نشوف بس احنا
ننتظر لانه راي العلماء المختصين في هذا
الجانب هو الراي اللي ناخذ فيه بالاخير
طيب بسوي انه هو عاده تفسير انه حدوث
الزلازل بشكل عام دائما بيكون نفس الشيء
صح
نفس الشيء طبعا اكيد يعني دائما الصفائح
تتحرك وفي مناطق محدده تصير عندها هذه
الحركه الزلازل فهل لب الارض وتحركها او
تغيرها اللي قاعد يصير على مئات الالاف من
السنين
واكثر طبعا هل هذا له علاقه ما شفت يعني
لحد الحين خبر يتكلم عن هذا الموضوع الى
الان
خلينا ناخذ الموضوع اللي وراه لان هذا
اعتقد مو واضح وما ابي احط معلومه بتحلل
وبتربط الاشياء تعرف ببعض وخصوصا انه يعني
الزلازل صارت وقال لك خلاص انه يعني هذا
العالم راح ينتهي هذه نهايتنا يا دكتور
احنا المشكله الزلازل قاعد تصير في كل
مكان في حول العالم حتى في هناك خريطه
متكامله فيها تفاصيل كثيره
للزلازل على مر السنوات الطويله فهذا امر
يصير يعني قبل فتره في ايران في الولايات
المتحده في ما ادري في الدول هذه تصير
فيها دائما زلازل ساعات خفيفه وساعات
كبيره فهذا امر طبيعي يعني في ناس تعتقد
انه مثلا الله سبحانه وتعالى غاضب على
البشر فيعطيهم زلازل صديقنا جون مفتاح في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يدرس
الدكتوراه في علم الثقوب السوداء يقول
الزلازل تحصل في كل مكان حتى على الكواكب
الاخرى حتى في الشمس يعني انا اعطيك مثال
انسايت اللي حاطينه على المريخ قاس
الزلازل قبل فتره يمكن ثلاث زلازل على سطح
المريخ يعني الله سبحانه وتعالى يعاقب منه
المواد العضويه الموجوده هناك مثلا فاعتقد
احنا احيانا نربط الامور بطريقه
اللي تشعرنا
نحن ما وصلنا وسكنا هناك يعني لسه ما تحقق
حلمنا هناك علشان تصير الدنيا تغضب طيب
وحلمك طبعا انت ننقل
ونعيش هناك في المريخ وكده بس خليني اقول
لك ليه الموضوع الاخر قالوا طيب لا مو لب
الارض لا هذا المذنب الاخضر اللي مر
بالقرب من الارض وانه هذا الموضوع من 50
سنه لا برضو اوكي طبعا بكل تاكيد لان هذه
الاشياء يعني شنو بتاثر في جاذبيتها
جاذبيتها اقل من القمر اذا كان هناك شيء
المفروض طبعا وليس هذا الكلام صحيح ياثر
على الارض كان القمر اقرب القمر ممكن
تاثيرها اكبر من تاثير اي مذنب يمر على
مسافه ابعد من من القمر
فاعتقد هذا
طيب موضوع الحيوانات هذا موضوع من اكثر
المواضيع اللي منتشره بمعزل عن الطيور
بمعزل عن حتى الفيديو اللي حطيناه حق
الخرفان دائما يقال
الحيوانات عند احساس عالي باي تغير سيحدث
في الطبيعه او كارثه طبيعيه لاي مدى هذا
الكلام صحيح
هو سؤال وفي فيديوهات كثيره تبين هذا
الشيء قصصيا سرديا على مر التاريخ وهذا
مدون قبل حتى الميلاد بثلاث مئه سنه ان
هذه الاشياء تصير لكن علميا العلماء
ابحثوا فيها ولم يبثوا في الموضوع ابدا
الا انهم يعتقدون ان الحيوانات فعليا لا
تستطيع اكتشاف الزلازل حتى لو تشوفون
فيديو لا يعني ان الفيديو دليل على اللي
قاعد يصير العلماء حتى على فكره راحوا الى
مزارع ووضعوا اجهزه على خراف وابقار يعني
مجموعه من الحيوانات في المزرعه ودرسوها
لفتره حتى يشوفون اذا فعلا هم يقدرون
يكتشفون الزلازل ولا لا ما وصلوا الى
نتيجه يعني نقدر نقول عنها انها قاطعه
فهذا ايضا نحتاج الى سنوات حتى نعرف
وابحاث كثيره يعني اكيد الخرفان هذي اللي
بتدور مو هي اللي تنبات يعني
[ضحك]
اعتقد في عندنا مشكله
يعني في الابحاث العلميه شنو تقول تقول ان
الانسان لما يفقد السيطره على الاشياء من
حوله يبحث عن تفاسير تريحه يعني واحده من
التجارب اللي سوها على الناس افقدوهم حاسس
الكنترول على بعض الاشياء والروهم صور
فيها نقاط لما نقاط عشوائيه ما فيها اي
صوره ما فيها اي معلومات قالوا لهم شو
تشوفون في الصوره فكانوا يركزون فيها اللي
فقدوا الكنترول على حياتهم او على تفكيرهم
كانوا يشوفون انماط وصور موجوده فيها
بينما الناس اللي ما فقدوا الكنترول ما
كانوا يشوفون انماط ويشوفونها عشوائيه
تماما نحن دائما نبحث عن الانماط المشكله
وين تصير انه لما هذه الانماط تكون خاطئه
وما نبحث بشكل سليم كثير من الناس يعني
قاعدين يتكلمون بشكل سخيف جدا ويعطون يعني
وينهم وين كانوا قبل الموضوع هذا كنتوا
تقولوا لنا نبي يصير زلزال اذا انتوا
عارفين انه الخراف ولا الابقار اللي تدور
الدائره هذه معناتها ان راح يصير زلزال
فاعتقد الموضوع مو بهالسهوله هذه التحاليل
اللي قاعد تصير على الانترنت هذه
حضرتك من متابعتك لمواقع التواصل ايش
الاشياء اللي مثلا غير اللي قلناها اللي
فاتتك وحسيت انه الناس كيف بتفكر
يعني احنا خصوصا في العالم الاسلامي احنا
عندنا هذه الاشكاليه الكبرى انه دائما
نلقي اللوم على الناس ونخلي الناس هم
السبب في ان الله سبحانه وتعالى غاضب
عليهم جماعه يعني في بعض الدول فقيره وبعض
الدول في حروب وبعض الدول عندها مشاكل بما
فيه الكفايه يعني ما تحتاج انه احد يضربها
زياده
فالمساله هذه طبيعيه والناس لو يفكرون
شويه بعقولهم لو يفكرون شويه بمنطق
ويروحون الى العلماء راح يكتشفون الاجابات
الصحيحه لمثل هذه الاسئله اما الاشياء
الثانيه اللي مثل الكائنات الحيه اللي
تدور او النمل اللي يدور حوالين نقطه
معينه هذه نهائيا ما لها معنى اللي عنده
هذا النوع من الفكر عنده لخبطه تامه في
اكتشاف الروابط اللي ما لها اي وجود في
هذا العالم فاعتقد احنا يمكن المشكله
الاساسيه اللي احنا نعاني منها هذا
الاتهامات اللي نوجهها للمساكين البشر
اللي موجودين بدل ان نطلب من الله سبحانه
وتعالى العون لهم وبدل من نساعدهم وتدزهم
يعني نتبرع لهم طبعا انت اليوم غردت عن
هذا الموضوع وكان واضح غضبك الشديد من هذا
الموضوع وبكل الاحوال يعني هي الان مرحله
فعلا الاساس فيها هي محاوله انقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذه محاوله انقاذ الناس من تحت الانقاض
يعني وحصر انه او تخفيف يعني حجم الكارثه
اللي جالس بيصير حول العالم